okay you
[Music]
readying in
a the idea of the the scene should be
that they're even though they're not
making it up as they go along it should
feel like a live performance yeah in a
little pub in Dublin I just love the
idea of little riffs that like felt like
okay I can see a 15-year-old kid doing
that so it's nothing to comp so I just
love that
[Music]
um it's got to be a marriage of of
creativity between a kid who's on garage
band who has beats with the girl who who
knows three chords her contribution
guitar wise has to be really simple and
the audience have to go I totally buy
that I think there's notes that can kind
of hang through the chorus like
mhm I'm not living in your life
you're not living in you're saying keep
four in the
[Music]
floor and I'm and I'm all you got and
she's kind of singing it to the audience
but she's also straining to to to speak
to him and he's coming back to her now
he can't you know and won't sing so it
would be kind of absurd in this movie if
suddenly he was like a a cheering or
something or singing act being the kid
he is living in the flats and hanging
out with the guys doing drill he might
do a little rap so I've been trying to
write from the point of view of a
14-year-old Dublin boy well you you once
well and this is my best effort this
isn't my dumbing down to try and get
into his head this is the best rap I can
do woman guess what cut from the same
cloth 14 years in the same block nine
long months in your belly down to the
I still wasn't ready 3 days late I
arrive at the party smile on my face
you're welcome me hearty give me the bit
just before um so we girl we're Cut From
the Same Cloth everything you feel I
feel the same loss I see your eyes in
the Mirror Saint angel devil sinner than
I don't have anything
[Music]
else still here in the High Life bang
and she's like hell you know so if he's
saying what I realized at the end of all
this is actually we dead similar it's
actually weirdly moving yes do you know
what I mean I actually think it can be
for a second you think it's funny and
then it like hits you with a killer
emotional line we living a
highing in a
high we're up on the
highl and it's a fine night to feel
alive we're living the
[Music]
high